for the people who have seen the Arnold
stuff and are maybe less familiar with
what's happening in your world of
bodybuilding at the moment what are the
differences between Arnold zero and
yours now in classic physique like
physically yeah essentially
I mean obviously you look back at sports
too everything progresses over time we
get more efficient with nutrition with
dieting with Peds with rest with
recovery everything just gets more
efficient and everything excels and you
push limits further and further so now I
mean
open bodybuilding is just you look at it
and you don't even question that they're
even the same classes no limitations no
weight limits dude they're on stage at
300 pounds like three percent body fat
just [__] monsters like huge stuff
you can't even fathom like when I see
them in person so I'm like wow that's a
real person which is insane but back in
back in the early days it was purely
like it was bigger upper bodies legs
weren't massive you weren't shredded it
was more about being full and round and
just like aesthetic and which is what
classic physique was brought in for but
even so the contrast classic physique
versus like the Arnold era it's way
leaner now it's still it's getting to
just as lean as the open bodybuilders
it's like shredded glutes you know your
ass is just right it at the end of the
day feathered quads just looks like you
have no body fat on you and probably
probably about the same way I think
Arnold was 240 on stage approximately
and my weight cap is 240 I'm about 239
when I weigh in so we're about the same
weight just like now it's required to be
a lot less body fat so if you put
uh Arnold and serge nubrey uh on stage
now they would look
aesthetically pleasing but that
condition would be significantly
different to the guys that are up there
now yeah it would be yeah it wouldn't be
the same
but what would be interesting is if you
could put Arnold to be born in 1990 and
then come up in this time those genetics
and those with all the stuff now what
would he look like surgery Bray would be
even bigger freak Arnold's a goat
because he did it first but I think
Sergeant Bray would be like insane to
see in our generation
is there a part of you that
wishes obviously you'd have to the
family would have to come back in the
misses and all of that stuff but is
there a part of you that wishes that you
could have had a crack during the Golden
Era as well
no I've never really thought of that
honestly I really think this era right
now just perfectly like where I'm meant
to be and obviously it's been working
out pretty [__] great so far so I
don't temptate with that I'm just
grateful for where I'm at
I read a story that you bought an
inversion table
is this true I did but it came in it
came with a 100 like page pamphlet and
like 500 like instructions to put it
together and I never put it together
right so there's a story that says you
bought an inversion table so that you
could make yourself a quarter of an inch
taller so that you could get an extra 10
pounds weight limit in your category I
tried yeah I did but I didn't put it
together I went to a chiropractor
consistently and they have a machine
pictures
is that not just the medieval rack is
that not a torture thing you've got a
peasant with one of those floppy caps on
yeah
we'll get you one inch taller literally
yeah it looks more like Frankenstein you
like sit in this machine like upright
and then it tilts you down and they have
a thing around your waist that just
pulls your spine right and I did that
for a while but I'm like I'm just over
six one so I'd have to agree in a full
inch to be over six two so I'm like I
would never do it but I also don't want
to shrink so I I've definitely tried a
few things I hang from bars all the time
to elongate my spine it's also just good
for your spine but yes classic physique
is just a battle to be taller
essentially to make your weight
I've seen a bunch of rumors on the
internet saying that if the timing was
right you would roll straight from a
classic physique show potentially into
an open show definitely thought about it
yeah have you really I have but there's
no open show with after the Olympia
there's like one in Japan but I would
want to do like a decent show I'd rather
Stack Up Beside like a top 10 Olympian
and see like how do you think you'd get
on
it depends on the show if you were to
put me in the Olympia
if you put me in Olympia the way I look
in classic right now I don't think I
would do top I would hit the top ten but
I think if I was able to like be a
little bit less leaner and Fuller and
like I always have to die down about
five pounds of muscle just to make my
weight so if I were able to be like full
as [__] like sometimes I'm like checking
pictures when I'm four weeks out I have
a high carb day I'm like I'm gonna open
bodybuilder right now this is crazy I
would love to just see what this looks
like on stage I think I could be like
top
give me a year and I think I could be
top 15 in like Olympia but there's no
there's no part of you that's like I
should give that a crack
no more than just that like this banter
like yeah I just really truly like I
love classic physique and I love what it
like pushes what it inspires people to
be more so than like when I was young I
literally was about to quit bodybuilding
in 2016 because there I turned Pro and I
was like I have there have to be 300
pounds or go down to men's physique and
I wasn't wearing board shorts and I
wasn't getting 300 pounds so I was gonna
retire but then literally that year
classic physique came out and I was like
this is for me I'll give it a shot and
then it just ran with it
yeah it seems so perfect in terms of the
timing for you in terms of being able to
find a sport that you actually enjoyed
that wasn't going to make you go too
freaky so what would you need to do
let's say that you did go across to open
what would you have to do to your
Physique in order to be able to
uh improve
a lot of it would be so right now I give
my body a lot of rest after the Olympia
I could be once a year and I take like
three months off the Olympia and then
coming back it's just like relearning
proper training patterns perfecting my
form like making sure I'm healthy and so
if I were to really want to do the open
I'd have to like take like a week off
the rest and then get back to work hold
all that weight and just start growing
for a full eight month and I don't push
food hard right now I go like I'll cycle
my calories if I start to get too fat
I'm like oh I don't pull it back down I
would just have to like lean into the
fat put on a little chill I wouldn't be
like fat fat but I like being lean
consistently lean enough so I feel good
I'd have to put on a lot of weight and
just eat consistently my training would
be the exact same it would be mainly
food a little bit more PDS of course but
just kind of dabbling around that I
think I could do it with just food
though
that'd be [__] great man I would like
to say it's such a shame that you can't
do that there's um
the 100 mile record for endurance racing
running and the 24 hour record for a
while when it was still a relatively new
title were often broken together yeah
because I think it takes
I might be wrong let's say it takes like
uh
14 hours or 12 hours or something to get
100 and then people would just continue
that pace or try and continue that pace
here and break the 24 Zach bitter this
guy from Austin did it he broke both
records in one it'd be so [__] cool
for somebody to like break through one
and then go and go to the next place at
a really great show I don't even think
like like I said if they let me do both
on the same day it wouldn't be good
because I'm too sucked down so I think I
would look pretty small up there what
body fat do you step on stage at you got
any idea you ever been in a dexa I
haven't no I don't even try and guess
because everyone on the internet's like
oh Ronnie Coleman came out and said he
was like zero percent or something and
people were like I don't think that's
possible if I had to guess I think it
would be like four I think it was just
[__] around but people took it
seriously but I think I would be around
four or five if I had to like be
conservative
and to get into the open category you'd
have to you would be able to lose a tiny
bit of condition yeah a little bit Yeah
my like because my structure it would
kind of make up for my conditioning I
think we'll get back to talking to Chris
in one minute but first I need to tell
you about element
I'm gonna look there you're gonna throw
it and I'm just going to catch it
because I'm a I'm in I'm epic right
we'll get back to talking to Chris in
one minute but first I need to tell you
about element element is a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
gluten no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other BS it is the
way that I've started my morning every
single day for over three years now
video guy Dean uses it and it is an
awesome beautiful very enjoyable drink
proper hydration plays a critical role
in reducing muscle cramps and fatigue
whilst optimizing brain health and
regulating appetite best of all they've
got a no BS no questions asked refund
policy with unlimited duration so you
can buy it and if you do not like it for
any reason you can get your money back
and you don't even need to return the
box that's how confident they are that
you love it head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with any purchase
that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom
yeah aiming for you that Bennett